hi I'm Seth Rogen I play Pumbaa and the
Lion King and I'm Billy Eichner and I
played Timon and Disney's The Lion King
that's right we are now gonna take a
BuzzFeed quiz about do you ship or sink
these iconic best friend duo's the word
ship obviously meaning to kind of like
the thing yeah I think to mean you don't
like the thing you know let's do it
let's do it
[Music]
Woody and Buzz Lightyear from Toy Story
ship burden has asked me feet ship I
love that wonderful gay couple burn or
anything second Zack and Cody from The
Suite Life of Zack and Cody
I know who they are yeah I'm too old
think about that get a wife we're gonna
be killed on social media for saying
that Janis Ian and Damien for mean girl
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's a gay icon he is right we
let yes yeah a man from Mean Girls Lizzy
Caplan there's some more no I'm happy
here and if you want to do figured if I
wanted to single yeah Marcus and Mike
from bad boys I ship that you might well
read ok microphone over his last name is
I was a big bad boys fan you were I like
the movie bad dude ok I don't know if it
holds up I won't hold it against you
thank you making another one
thank God did they I did some punch up
work on bad boys - you did I sure did
who better to capture the voice of
Martin Lauri yeah then you set the road
alright we'll ship Tweedledee and
Tweedledum from Alice in Wonderland ship
they're the best body image visibility I
say I am sure I am shaped similar we
stand for Tweedledee and Tweedledum we
ship we ship and Han Han Solo and
Chewbacca from Star Wars you got a ship
these guys come out nice and Ford ship
them out the door oh ah
Chewbacca's even on that look I should
knock another count you Balkan they kind
of it like he kind of has like an 80s
but Chewbacca actually is kind of hot
yeah because yeah he's quaffed yeah he's
very quiet SpongeBob and Patrick from
SpongeBob SquarePants you Schiphol you
ship UPI Connick yeah they're iconic why
wouldn't you ship them what's not to
ship something about it feels homophobic
just thing I would agree yeah
for a lot of these things yeah that's
actually very true Betty and Veronica
from Riverdale I've never seen this I'm
old and I don't watch no but I know that
on Twitter I'm supposed to love it you
are and so I'm gonna say [ __ ] I'm gonna
sink in oh my god are fresh again sunk
the entire caster riverdale today and
don't forget we're all the reasons you
think Iron Man and spider-man from
spider-man homecoming I'm gonna say I'm
saying what enough
spider-man every week enough Ash and
Pikachu from Pokemon I'm not a Pokemon
perceiver think Oh Marty McFly and Doc
Brown baddest [ __ ] yep
gotta ship them John Mulaney has a great
joke about why are they friends that's
really funny
Oh John Mulaney John the lady check out
Jafar and Iago from Aladdin sync them
really far I think you were jab you like
your Bert how could you not like the
legendary Gilbert Godfried and Perkins
and Leslie Knope from Parks and Rec I
was on that show so you got it I'm gonna
ship them no you'll run into these
people yeah I literally no Amy Poehler
Stefon Evan from super bad ah I got a
ship them because I exactly timon and
pumba Virage ship it all the way then
they ship it right out of town that's
right steal the movie still the quiz
yeah
am i done now I'm reading about how a
baker confused Moana and marijuana
literally that's the headline another
Disney tired
you